you guys all know Stephen Hawking the
brilliant and renowned physicist the
movie the theory of everything just came
out about his life he had some
interesting things to say about sort of
the future of humanity and and sort of
how we've evolved and how we may
continue to evolve we've got an
interesting quote from him right here
the human failing I would most like to
correct his aggression it may have had
survival advantage in caveman days to
get more food territory or a partner
with whom to reproduce but now it
threatens to destroy us all a major
nuclear war could be the end of
civilization and possibly the end of the
human race the quality I would most like
to magnify is empathy it brings us
together in a peaceful loving state I
thought this was kind of interesting cuz
it's nothing new here yeah we should be
better to ourselves and to our neighbors
and things like that but sometimes when
something comes from somebody as bright
as a Stephen Hawking perhaps Kim we
should pay a little more attention Oh
dr. Hawking has also expressed his
concerns over AI be coming to rampant
and being able to control the you know
humans in general i guess or society in
a way and it's kind of it's on both
sides of the spectrum in that way uh I
don't really agree with him on the AI
thing but I do pretty much agree with
him on this I we're gonna kill each
other yeah do you think the robots are
gonna kill us or we're gonna kill each
other first i'm actually more concerned
about the aggression is talking about
his recent comments because as someone
who's on the internet okay here we go
again you do see a lot of that there's a
lack of empathy that I've never
experienced before my life maybe I was
naive like you do stories about domestic
violence and people totally give others
a pass for beating the [ __ ] out of one
another yeah and I don't really know
when that was okay or when people
thought it was acceptable but I'll give
you a quick example we did a story about
uh afro man who is a rapper literally
hitting another woman in the face
because she had the audacity to get up
on stage and dance and have a good time
at his show she's a fan of his right and
so we put that video up online of course
we condemned his actions and a huge
population of people were like well he
was justified he was so
actually her eyes by this are you
[ __ ] kidding me right now yeah he hit
a fan in the face for having a good time
at a show so like that aggression that's
just one specific example that
aggression is becoming more and more
prevalent if you ask me and it's
problematic do you think there's
something about the online yeah it's
making it happen like so for example
back in the day if you had to hunt for
your food you could get out a certain
amount of aggression in a normal way or
guys that play football you're getting
out a certain amount of physical
aggression we're now everyone's just
sitting behind their computer all day so
your regression comes out in ways in a
something like that where it's so clear
like what's right and wrong yet you
still find yourself expressing
aggression because maybe you're not
getting out and in a very human way
people forget what it's like when
they're not face-to-face with someone so
like you don't realize there's a person
on the other end of this who is reading
this has feelings and thoughts and value
and you know when I'm face to face with
you like there's no way I'd be like oh
you know but yeah maybe if I but you
would say that but no because yeah I but
like that's that's a terrible example
actually but you know you forget that
level of humanity and empathy when
you're not next to a human and I think
that's something we haven't evolved with
yet as as technology starts to evolve
more and more yeah I think it makes a
good point but I think another part of
it is the people are frustrated right
now you know people have more student
loan debt than ever before it's really
hard for young people to find jobs and
so when things aren't going the right
way in your life you're looking for a
scapegoat and so I understand that
aspect of it as well but yeah I mean if
we had a little more empathy and we
understood the perceptions of other
people I think that we would live in a
much better society so why don't our
governmental leaders talk about that
nobody really ever Obama did it a little
bit originally you know in 2008 when he
came in he gave that big speech in Egypt
about understanding different people
that but we really don't do that anymore
right now they're even from Obama all
the way down is there anyone that really
talks about sort of understanding your
neighbor and all that while why don't we
do that well the government doesn't lead
by example at all in fact I mean we
demonize people that are different from
us on a regular basis and so if you have
leadership spreading those types of
ideas of course it's gonna seep into the
general population when you treat all
Muslims
as if they're all extremists uh you know
as a government you are sending a
message to your people to citizens and I
think that that's dangerous yeah all
right people we're going to do a little
test here and you all be empathetic
pleasant lovely and wonderful in the
comments right down below I don't want
to hear any [ __ ] about these two little
only if you want to do it but that's it
all right right there you know where it
is subscribe comment